breaks down as he pleads with staff in
india's biggest
covenant 19 hospital to admit his wife
lakshmi
she's lying in the back of an ambulance
breathing with the help of an oxygen
cylinder
he tells al jazeera they came here after
being turned away by
other hospitals
i have no one else except my wife and
child who i've left on the road with an
acquaintance
there's no one to look after us we
aren't getting a bed and i've tried many
hospitals but there's no one around to
give us a bed
with folded hands i have pleaded with
the acquaintance to take care of my
child
tensions run high outside the hospital
where family members tell staff
they have nowhere else to go
[Music]
but lorc nayak already has 1850 patients
and
only 1500 beds staff told us
hundreds are lying on the floor our work
is very hard we try to help and guide
people but they don't listen
people are becoming very frustrated some
even become
but eventually after waiting for hours
most to give up and begin their search
for a bed
again hoping to find a hospital where
someone has been discharged
despite being india's biggest covert 19
hospital staff at lochnayak told us
it too is running low on oxygen supply
when the delhi regional government took
the matter to the high court
india's solicitor general told it let's
try and not be a crybaby
50 people died in the capital after
their oxygen supply ran out
and on saturday six patients died in the
state of punjab because of the same
reason healthcare workers say they are
helpless in the face of such a calamity
we need oxygen immediately and my our
persons are wandering here and there for
oxygen
but there is no help no hope
butter leaves lok nayak after his
ambulance driver tells him
his wife will die if they keep waiting
there
elizabeth al jazeera new delhi
dr ritter schmalek is the director of
radix healthcare private hospital in new
delhi he says india is
facing one of the biggest battles in its
modern history
we are in the midst of one of the most
previous
challenges our country has faced since
the partition
of 1947 we are seeing in a
very very vulnerable population
continuously
in search for oxygen basic beds
rem de severe medicines and things
even like paracetamol in smaller towns
in india
0.35 million new cases each day
are being recorded and this is when we
do not have adequate testing
happening on gra on ground we are seeing
in
a massive surge of young population
getting affected
by the second wave of kovid and i truly
believe
that we have not achieved the peak yet
we are going to see the peak in the
coming
one and or one and a half weeks from now
there is
massive shortage of oxygen in our
hospitals
today morning we just had 10 minutes of
oxygen
left in our own hospital there have been
more than 45 deaths recorded deaths
in delhi large delhi hospitals because
of lack of
oxygen and we are on oxygen
sos calls and and until and unless the
government provides us with oxygen which
is an essential medicine
to fight covet this is the only medicine
which actually works
this is something which is the need of
the iron if we do not do that we will
see a lot of bloodshed
in delhi and other parts of the country
i i believe that
any patient who dies can you stay or can
i stay without
oxygen for even a minute the answer is
no oxygen is a
basic necessity especially for a disease
like covid
where in rem de severe fatty flu and
other drugs have questionable clinical
trials
oxygen is the only essential medicine we
have something in by the government
called the essential medics
medicines act in that the first medicine
is oxygen and
if we do not have oxygen how do we fight
a pulmonary infection like covid
which is so so grievous in nature and so
infectious